one good morning Millennials and welcome
back to the toast happy Tuesday hope
everyone's having a great day
speaking of great one of the Grits the
greatest ever do it where is that from
we always say I hope you're having a
great day
we always say that I don't know where
it's from but it's obviously from
something like a movie or something yeah
I don't know
I don't know it's giving Fat Bastard
it's giving Russian
no it's Fat Bastard where was he from
that bastard is Austin Powers but the
only Fat Bastard of course but where was
he like oh
where does he hail from what's his
background I'm not sure although the
only
um Fat Bastard quotes that I really
resonate with are twins basil and uh
Cobbs are the enemy what about I eat
because I'm unhappy I'm unhappy because
I eat I didn't know I thought that was
Socrates
I didn't know that was fabulous
the same but different I eat because I'm
unhappy and I'm unhappy because I eat
like that's like that vicious you're
always talking about like oh you're
trying to get dressed for something you
feel disgusting fat like everything
you're wearing doesn't fit you and the
only thing that makes you feel better is
eating yeah or like you go to a party or
something and you just like are not
feeling yourself you're just like
insecure and you go home and like you
just have to eat right like eatings but
got you to that even though you're
insecure because of the eating
yeah but that's just life man you know I
eat because I'm insecure I'm insecure
because I eat
you're not fat because I hate you I hate
you because you're bad
so those are just some words to
hopefully not live by philosophical
words of wisdom to start you off on your
day you know courtesy of that bastard
and the law is reason free from Passion
always always
it's the one you're wearing a very cute
sweatshirt today would you like to tell
the group about it I would because it is
our mama crew neck from our toast Mama
collection that we released right before
Mother's Day so you could get yourself a
little something sweet for you and we
have Bebe merch and toddler clothing
merch
[__] you are asking the wrong world
right no it's like it goes up to 45 T so
it's like t-shirts for kids it's the
cutest designs ever this little
podcasting bear I read on page six that
actually Harry was running around town
in his toast t-shirt he was spotted in
his toast t-shirt looking so cute and of
course that you know size and color
immediately sold out once you know
everybody heard world was wearing it was
like the Kate Middleton effect
so you can still get all of these things
are available at toastmarch.com we have
uh onesies for babies and newborns all
the way up to 24 months we have T-shirts
for toddlers and then we have crewnecks
T-shirts tote bags and mugs for The
Mamas it was just like a little gift to
The Mamas 100 also if there's a mama in
your life and you like don't know what
to get her that's it's really for the
aunties to buy gifts for the mothers in
my opinion yeah do you want one of these
that says the toast auntie
yeah that would be nice extremely Niche
collection I think there'll probably be
like 13 of us but we're a strong but
Mighty crowd and 13 people deserve a
crew neck they do and what I think it's
worth it just to make the little tweak I
agree
well you're looking gorgeous today oh my
God thank you so are you tan legs oh my
God tan legs this is like an old spray
tan I'm showing a lot of thigh on the
YouTube today which is why the iPad is
covering like my whole pussy's out like
it's not cool it's a nice family show
okay
sure we're not a nice family show no
like your whole [__] isn't out oh it's
just a leg it's just like a lot of thigh
you know it's just thigh
it's a lot of thigh like any thighs too
much thigh no no I showed that yesterday
on the toes it's that time of year I
gotta get comfortable showing leg on the
toast you know it's 65 degrees today
it'll hit 70 by the time we leave the
studio yeah I'm struggling with that
because I can't like get a spray tan so
my legs are so pale maybe you should you
know sit outside and get a real Tan on
your leg that like doesn't happen for me
same so I know that there are like
self-tanning products that are pregnancy
safe they're like made with just like
coffee oh
um which I could do that but I haven't
like commit it hasn't started to bother
me enough yet that I'm not showing my
legs but I do have like a cute few
dresses it would be nice to wear on the
show but not in the state of these legs
well how are pregnant women self-tanning
their legs like you can't bend over you
got a baby in front of you you know oh I
guess we're just going up to Mid
or maybe like we're having our husbands
I can touch here I can reach it I can
reach it oh so I guess you'd be sitting
yeah yeah reach reach reach I don't give
a reach I don't give a ring no I don't
so maybe that's what's next for me
perhaps but what was also next for me
this morning was I listened to a
wonderful podcast that got me in the
chatty mood yeah two of the chattiest
girls I know so true Shannon and
snatchler the snatcher one on Shannon's
podcast when we were in Nashville
Shannon just does a premium did you
listen as audio or YouTube I listened to
his audio because I was doing my makeup
but you know how much I love watching
videos so it was like
I feel like I need to watch it again as
a video because I'm missing Keith
elements and they're gorgeous girls they
got all dressed up and they get all
dressed up like I want to watch it I
watched um on YouTube it was a gorgeous
way to get dressed I love having
something to watch in the mornings it
kind of makes like the whole getting
ready process so much more fun you know
I really felt like I was getting ready
with my girls we were chuckling we were
laughing we were getting deep yeah of
course so it was really enjoyable it
made me want to put on a good show today
it inspired you it inspired me to
podcast my little heart out just to
podcast the hardest you've ever
podcasted in your life no but not too
hard like I don't want to be like I'm
trying too hard you know yeah yeah I do
know
why are you smiling like that because
it's a it's a delicate balance it is a
delicate balance like deliver a show
that has has it all but not too much of
it all yeah because people could sniff
that out
and you just have to be yourself but you
want to be your best self and how are
the stories today like kind of stories
are good yeah yeah the stories are
really strong the first four kind of
fell into slot immediately he's the best
and then the fifth was just like um some
random Biz news that will take us on a
tangent which is kind of my perfect
lineup yeah I agree like four solid
celeb stories and fifth Randomness that
will make us have something funny to say
very cool well my book club met last
night it was a great success in page six
it didn't make the stories I figured
because you would bring it up yeah we
met it was really uh a success you know
pretty much everyone hated the book
except Raquel she like loved it she
couldn't believe we all hated it which
is good you know at least somebody
should enjoy them she does the Margo of
the group but it doesn't really matter
like like the main event last night
wasn't the book it was the food like it
went all out on desserts on on trades it
was really just I ate so much like I I
was I actually got home and I was not
okay from how much I ate spaghetti steak
chicken rice sweet s'mores for dessert
two proteins wow yeah no there was like
three proteins there was also kebabs I
didn't have kebabs
it's just like I'm really hungry so
sorry it's kind of like a hard for me to
hear well
um you know the word kebab
like when you think of the word Kebab
what do you think of
Shish
I exclusively think of Shahs of Sunset
and like I really can't say the word
Kebab I have to say kebab
there are so many words like I say
differently seriously because of shots
of sunset is that where great comes from
maybe even when I like talk to or talk
about Mercedes Javi it's Mercedes yeah
Mercedes but if you were to buy a
vehicle Mercedes from Mercedes yeah I I
I can keep the two separate got it
you look like a piece of wood drives a
Mercedes she does actually and yes she
has to of course that's like Shannon has
to drive a Ford truck you know a new um
she does she was going down Shannon for
the road it really always took us where
we wanted to go a nice little reality TV
like
thing that happened is you know they
unfortunately canceled Shaws of sunset
which was so disgusting but Mercedes
actually works at the agency now
Mercedes not Mercedes Mauricio umanski's
company is she on their show she should
because she's reality TV gold she is but
she's still very much like a part of the
Bravo universe and there's a lot of
spin-off shows like ah some TV I was
watching had Traders on yeah it's like a
peacock show with all like the villains
from past reality TV shows and also some
lay people like who no lay people oh
like citizens citizens private citizens
Ordinary People I think that's what I
gleaned from the show I was kind of
trying to put the pieces together as I
was watching by the way I actually heard
that show was like amazing I heard that
too I watched an episode I didn't feel
that way but I also didn't
watch a whole episode and I didn't know
what was going on so it's not fair to
say yeah but it wasn't like feeling like
oh my God I'm pulled in no I had heard
that that show like had a really unique
like concept not unique or just like a
good concept with good people and the
first season was kind of gangbusters
they had like you know past villains
Brandy Glanville Jax Taylor yeah I had
heard people they weren't all villains
oh like um Kyle Cook is in it Ari a
little bit of a villain Ari line Dyke he
actually like was a villain okay fine I
guess anyone could be a villain Kyle
cookie is not available no I just us no
no I think he's like a villain no he's
like
the affable I guess he's like Tom
Sandoval before scandaval like only a
villain in our eyes yeah I saw on Tick
Tock Tom Sandoval um has fled the
country he was at the LAX International
Airport probably getting out of Dodge
before the reunion
um did they know where he was going no
he was just like going through security
and fun fact he did not have TSA
pre-check maybe he was just going on
vacation well I also don't know like if
everything we know about Tom Sandoval up
into this point would lead me to believe
he's gonna like lean in you know people
are gonna be talking about him more than
ever running away is not something it's
not you know it's very out of character
for him yeah
I mean he like loves it he's like still
in the house if he was a runner right
he's a runner he's a track star
but it's just like what I saw on Tick
Tock which means you know it's obviously
true obviously
so I guess that's all so the book club
was good that was the book club was good
yeah I don't have a lot to catch up with
everyone on I like didn't do much
like worth discussing yesterday
yeah she was just like kind of blurry I
don't even remember we had our bhg right
we had our big day out with Harry Harry
actually came to the studio what did he
say when he got home what did he think
he was really impressed with the
operation with the lights and the cords
yeah he was like Mom you've got a really
good thing going I'm proud of you he
actually sat in this chair right here I
knew it felt different when I sat in it
today and he was just kind of taking in
mesmerized by the lights he loved the
phone stand he loves the phone stand and
then we took him out to lunch he needed
pizza and it was just like an amazing
day like when I got home Ben was like
how was your day and I'm like well it
was amazing you know and that's not
something you usually hear on a Monday
no not from like what normally would
have been like a standard work day right
I wasn't like it was good productive how
was your day I said Ben at an amazing
day I actually think I said you know I
had the best day with rolled did it not
to be so annoying but did it get like
your ovaries tingling [__] off no
honestly like the way I couldn't even
eat I was like Harry like are you
choking Harry you need water Harry what
do you need Harry's falling out of the
high chair like honestly no if you're
gonna ask a question I'm gonna be
[__] honest no okay okay yeah that
hasn't happened for you at all through
this process even with Michaela every
time you're with the kids like you have
the best time but it does not leave you
other people are like my ovaries are too
no honestly when when I'm spend time
with the kids like I'm so fulfilled but
I also like I hit a point where I just
like slowly back away and Retreat to my
bedroom like it's a lot yeah like and
I'm when I'm with the kids I'm not
focusing on like the ovary Love part I'm
focused on like the laborious part I'm
like okay I've had enough gotta go like
I love these kids we take a pillow for
them get out of the car okay you know
okay just had to ask yeah because I'm
sure people are thinking it oh were they
like I feel so fulfilled my nieces and
nephews like honestly it's enough for me
like you and Olivia did too good of a
job having the most perfect poo poo
children that what what could I possibly
offer you know can you bring to the
table nothing like okay
yeah rolled Levi
seriously like it's good okay
we'll leave it at that yeah we will
we'll Circle back do you know what's
good for you we'll Circle back in a year
yeah
so now that all the questions have been
asked right now that you've like invaded
my personal ovary space you're not
touchy about that no no I'm not when
it's from um
people I don't know of course that's
[__] weird like I'm not gonna say her
name but like you know what I'm talking
about like
actually you weren't even there I was
with Olivia oh my God she was like what
about you like I don't know this person
at all she does not know this person
what about you you don't want to do it
and I was thinking of like making up a
lie like I'm like oh my God like just to
make her feel bad because like [__] off
[__] yeah that's crazy and by the way
it's nobody juicy like it's not a
celebrity or an influencer it's just
like some [__] yeah that's who I
already got bad vibes from the first
time I met her I just felt like I didn't
like her yeah no that's so crazy and you
know I'm coming just from a place of
curiosity and like no take your time
turn you're completely fine like over
the weekend we had um brunch with a
bunch of girls some who are pregnant
some who have kids some are in the
stages like everybody's in different
stages and we all were talking about and
everyone was just bringing up like where
they're at and I didn't I don't feel any
that's a safe space like yeah and if I
know you and love you but like if I
don't like you better watch your [__]
mouth around me [__] yeah but safe
space is a safe space and toast is a
safe space because it's also like the
element of like list broadcasting no
like people were wondering you're you're
within your right you're well within
your rights to ask okay okay cool
cool you're welcome now I think without
further
here are the past five stories that you
need to know
and today's episode is brought to you by
betterhelp thank you better help for
sponsoring today's episode so it's so
easy to get caught up in what everyone
else needs from you never take a moment
to think about what you need for
yourself because the most important
person in your life spoiler alert is you
what is Charity need when we spend all
of our time giving it can leave us
feeling stretched out burned out feeling
thin not in the way that you might want
therapy can give you the tools that to
find more balance in your life so you
can keep supporting others without
leaving yourself behind so if you're
thinking of starting therapy give better
help a try it's a really great
accessible platform that is like a very
good entry into therapy I know a lot of
people who have had great success with
better help um what's so great about it
is that it's all done entirely online so
there's so many elements of if you're
like a socially awkward person there's
so many elements of therapy that can be
like genuinely painful like waiting in
the waiting room like seeing other
people and then just like the social
interactions of it but it's all done
online with betterhelp
um it's designed to be convenient
flexible and suited to your schedule you
fill out a brief questionnaire and then
you'll get matched with a licensed
therapist and one of the parts that I
like about it best is that you can
switch therapists at any time for no
additional charge and no additional
weirdness like there's no awkward like
hey what's going on oh I'm going to
another like it's just awkward
um so you can video chat you can phone
call you can text really any sort of
medium whatever you're most comfortable
with with your um therapist find more
balance with betterhelp visit
betterhelp.com toast today to get 10 off
your first month that's betterhelp help
help.com toast to get 10 off your first
month today's episode is also brought to
you by article Summer's on its way I
mean I'm showing thigh
if that doesn't mean get your outdoor
patio set up then I don't know what does
have you been dreaming of ideas for your
outdoor space and how to make the most
of it well the best thing about summer
is getting to do all of your favorite
indoor things outside having meals
watching movies falling asleep on the
sofa everything is better Alfresco
including a glass of Pinot Grigio
article believes in delightful design
for every home and thanks to their
online only model they have really great
delightful prices too their curated
assortment of mid-century modern Coastal
industrial scandi and boho designs make
furniture shopping simple their team of
designers are all about finding the
perfect balance between style quality
and price and they're dedicated to
thoughtful craftsmanship that stand the
test of time and look good doing it they
offer fast affordable shipping across
the US and Canada and they won't leave
you waiting around you pick the delivery
time they'll send you updates every step
of the way I will say one of my favorite
parts of your house and probably like
the one thing I'm most jealous of is
your outdoor space you've got great
couches tables places to put your feet
dining tables I've had lunch with Harry
outside and I was actually there I think
at the beginning when you moved in where
you got a bunch of article pieces
delivered for your outdoor screened-in
situation and it was really so efficient
like we were able to do the toast we
knew that he would be coming after like
it was not a burden which I think
furniture delivery can be a lot of the
time clear your schedule you gotta clear
your schedule and just like wait around
like an [__]
not with article article is offering our
listeners 50 off their first purchase of
a hundred dollars or more to claim visit
article.com toast and the discount will
be automatically applied at checkout
that's article.com
toast for 50 off your first purchase of
a hundred dollars or more thank you
Claudia you're welcome our first story
Kim Kardashian is getting
some heat again after comments made on a
podcast yes I saw she was on Jay Shetty
but I didn't see what she was getting
backlash okay I'll tell you what she
said and then what people are saying so
here's what she said Kim Kardashian
speaks on the chaos of being a single
mom she admits that parenting is one of
the most challenging yet rewarding
things she has encountered in life she
said there are nights I cry myself to
sleep like holy [__] this [__]
tornado in my house like what just
happened actually this is perfect
regarding considering the conversation
we just had she went on Jay shetty's
podcast and had a conversation about
parenting and also being a single mom
she emphasized that even in the mess of
it all it is still the best chaos she
said everyone says the days are long and
the years are short and that couldn't be
like a more true statement it is the
most rewarding job in the entire world
there is nothing that can prepare you I
don't care how long you wait I don't
care what you're waiting for you are
never prepared
so people are um what's wrong with that
upset so she opened up about the chaos
in her home life saying that sometimes
she gets through the night hour by hour
to see if we're going to survive if a
tantrum comes in oh my God your life is
completely upside down and she talked
about like crying herself to sleep some
nights like just from the stress and
just the chaos of it all okay so people
are slamming her saying she's acting
like she's middle class and complaining
about her struggles as a single mom you
know she has a full staff and nannies to
help her and that she's not
right like allowed to complain okay I
mean I just so don't agree with that
like whatsoever
um
like I just don't like just because it's
different than other people's situations
doesn't mean she's not entitled to talk
about it she is a single mom she's also
I think feel like what we know about her
like yeah she has all this
infrastructure I'm sure she has like a
team of nannies and everything
um but she's like a really involved mom
and so as much as you have help like you
still want to do everything yourself and
your kids at the end of the day like
want their mom and I don't know I just
feel like she's entitled that's like
that thing like you know I'm drowning in
100 feet of water and you're drowning in
20 feet of water but we're both still
drowning so true I've never heard that
yeah I heard it on Olivia Jade's story
once and it actually really stuck with
me it's like people are allowed to
complain even if their situations are
different or better than yours right so
here are some of the the tweets around
okay of what people are saying just to
give Connor to like what people are
saying I just want to say I meant I
wanted to listen to what she had to say
because without the whole context of the
conversation like it's
it's not worth having a take on it but
then Shannon and since dropped their
episode right and so you were otherwise
I was otherwise occupied she said quote
Twitter Tweeter said she also talks if
she doesn't have a full staff of people
helping her what the [__] someone else
came has four nannies one assigned to
each kid motherhood is not hard nannies
are raising her kids she needs to stop
trying to act like she's middle class I
just want to say I'm like the biggest
Kim fan ever and I I don't know that to
be a fact that she is but she's a kid
where did I I don't know that either it
could be true but like where did we
learn that yeah and I at no point in
what she was saying did I feel like she
was trying to be middle class I mean
she's sitting there like looking like
you know like she's so famous she was oh
for a second I thought she was middle
class like I never [__] thought that
like that's not a valid and I also don't
think she was doing that thing that a
lot of celebrities do that bothers me
where they like try and be relatable
yeah where they um you know complain
about like relatable things that
everyone goes through but it's like you
actually don't go through that I
actually don't feel like that's what she
was doing I feel like one thing about
motherhood is like it really is like the
great equalizer like no matter
how many you know how much help you have
or how much money you have like everyone
especially like I feel like what we know
about the Kardashians like they're
really involved parents they don't just
like you know toss their kids to some
facility and like run away
um motherhood really is like the great
equalizer and yes certain people have
help but it's still like it takes a
village it takes a village and it's
still like a lot of pressure to raise
people you know what I mean and so I
feel like even if her day-to-day looks
different from other people's like she
still has a world of pressure on top of
her taking care of four kids like
running multiple businesses being a
single mom being a single mom but we
also you I don't think we talked about
this on the show but we kind of did
because that person
Jeremy Allen White's um ex-wife had said
that she's now a single mom and we were
like questioning to single motherhood
apply to divorced parents where the
father is in the picture no it's a good
question and you know what you know that
um Jeremy Allen White's Addison Timlin
his ex-wife actually changed her caption
from single mother to co-parent
because maybe she got like backlash I
was just curious I don't know what
qualifies a single mom I think Kim is
qualified as a single mom because when
she is divorced and two like Connie is
very um
you know
in and out in and out he like lived in
Wyoming for a while and he's like going
through stuff and I don't know I'm sure
he's involved but I think I would
consider her a single mom yeah I think
people are also questioning that
qualification too considering Kanye is
around and he's also you know Financial
right provider right that's true and he
also like wants to be with his kids he's
always making videos like trying to show
up yeah so there they were
triggered by her use of that term as
well yeah we actually did just have that
conversation I think off air I don't
know what is what constitutes a single
mom I don't know if being divorced
constitutes a single mom because you're
single and you're a mom right
and like when the kids are with you you
are single mothering yeah but the
difference between that and like
supposedly a widower is like a widower
doesn't get you know the weekends
custody right yeah I don't know
I don't know either and also we don't
know what her situation with Kanye is
right so if she's calling herself a
single mom like I'm gonna call her a
single mom too like yeah you know yeah
and I just it's crazy like it's so crazy
I'm sure this conversation was like
extremely fine and normal long like no
like long and in depth and like you just
take away the fact that she well she's
not allowed to cry at night because
she's stressing over one by her life
right
like who gave you permission right just
because you don't think like if you were
in that situation that you would cry
doesn't mean her feelings aren't valid
right no I don't agree with this
backlash I'm China in this backlash it's
no real to me okay but it's like very
real for people yeah well that's on them
yeah yeah oh per usual right just
because like just because somebody's
life is different and in your opinion
easier doesn't mean that they don't
struggle with something right
like that's just I don't I reject I
reject this backlash I don't know her
okay well I still want to watch the
interview because it looks good and and
she doesn't do podcasts a lot so it
became like we've never seen her before
and there's video
and most importantly there is video
right so I shall be watching watch she
shall are you ready for our next story
yeah some love news billionaire Jeff
Bezos is engaged to Lauren Sanchez after
nearly five years together wow it's been
five years I know they are really having
a week and I guess this whole big week
was the lead up to this big engagement
Amazon had Jeff Bezos and his girlfriend
Lauren Sanchez are engaged the pair in
the south of France for the canned Film
Festival where they have been hitting
the star-studded party circuit while
staying on his 500 million dollar yacht
with the mermaid resembling Lauren
adorning the prowl lest we not forget
rumors have been swirling this week as
Lauren was seen with a diamond ring on
her finger they have been Inseparable
since they started dating in 2018. like
very normal I know you know what between
you know the conversation we had about
them I think last week and this like I
ship I'm so here for this
age-appropriate you know long-term
relationship now of course
did he cheat on his wife with her
the timeline was like a little murky the
timeline's a little murky but you don't
know when people got separated when like
you know they went to separate bedrooms
yeah
etc etc so I don't know she was also
married too yeah there was like a little
there was a nefarious nature to the the
beginning of their relationship however
I'm okay with it five years of
commitment yeah and now an engagement
soon though that you know they'll be
engaged for a year and a half and get
married right at the plaza right just
like a couple of Millennials literally
yeah I mean that wedding is going to be
next level in terms of guest list yeah
like who at that point do you even
invite to your wedding everyone I think
they're gonna go big
yeah
it's nice it is nice I weirdly am
unbothered now me too and it's making
him much more likable I feel like he
went through a period of just being like
a clown you know like an alien like he
just like he's not in a lot of ways not
human yeah you know what I mean he feels
extraterrestrial maybe that's why he's
trying to go to space to be amongst his
people right yeah like that cowboy hat
you know like everything he does is like
a little [__] weird yeah he just like
can't be cool no but she feels very
normal to me
um
and I don't know I feel like she
normalizes like humanizes him in a sense
yeah and they're always together like
doing activities they went to Coachella
yeah you know they went to dinner with
Kim Kardashian which is the most normal
thing you could do right it's nice I
like it I like it too because I like it
yeah it's good um congrats to the happy
couple yeah her ring is beautiful I
think it was 20 carats which is insane
um and the only photos we really have
are like Blurry Paparazzi of them
outside so it's not like you know an
official Instagram announcement yeah but
hopefully we'll get that soon if they're
going to be as choogy as we think they
are I think we'll get like a full-blown
engagement photo shoot I think so maybe
in a field somewhere like a bachelor
couple I love that for them me too I
would love to see it or on the boat oh
of course maybe with with the statue in
tow
that'd be nice that would be are you
ready for our next story yeah another
bit of podcasting information because
Nick Jonas went on armchair expert and
he is talking about his tragic
performance with Kelsey ballerini that
landed him in therapy and as a Nick fan
and a Kelsey fan I did not know about
any of this what performance Nick Jonas
has revealed that his Infamous
performance with Kelsey ballerini at the
2016 Academy of Country Music Awards the
acms landed him in therapy he joined
Kelsey on stage for a rendition of her
song Peter Pan I love that just moments
after starting the duet off fine he
recalled his tragic off-key guitar solo
that seemingly marred the performance oh
guitar solo okay it's better than a
vocal solo I feel like when there are
performances and then people go into
like long solos that's like when
everybody goes and gets a snack so I
don't know he said a really good tragic
guitar solo debacle happened on live TV
I come out for my thing I rehearsed it a
million times I'm feeling really
confident about it not even really
thinking about it like it's going to be
problematic I started off it was fine
and as I walked towards her I just went
completely blank and I hit a wrong note
and blacked out basically and clocked
that it was wrong and I couldn't stop at
the time he poked fun at himself and
laughed along with the torn of jokes on
social media writing yes I screwed up
the solo thanks to a huge brain fart
we're all human and [__] happens yeah
but whoever made this is genius about
like a meme looking back on the mishap
years later he said in retrospect I can
kind of laugh about how big I thought it
was but it did travel more than I wish
it would have and it did cause me to go
to therapy until this day and hours
after unpacking it I can't really figure
out exactly what happened but I was
rushed to a car and rushed to a plane
right after it and I looked at my
manager and said I think that was bad I
was like in shock kinda like it was a
really traumatic moment that shaped the
pressure I put on myself to be perfect
and to be always on that's interesting I
have quite literally no idea what
performance this is which is so crazy
because I have to go watch it yeah of
course because I know everything
um
and I do feel I could understand how
this is devastating for him and I
actually think it's worse than his voice
giving out because we all know Nick
Jonas is a really good singer and so if
he did one performance and he sounded
bad like we could say it was an off day
I would never be like oh Nick Jonas has
been lip syncing his whole career like
he's an established good singer but I do
think he really Prides himself on being
a musician and to go out and do a guitar
solo and like totally [__] it up like
you look like you're playing pretend
yeah and I do kind of really respect his
acknowledging because I feel like
he definitely like is always trying to
be and do the most and like be perfect
and he's always been that way and it's
like kind of annoying
um but the fact that it's like something
he acknowledges and like Works through
in therapy it's like and I think it's
probably like from always being compared
to his brothers like that has to be so
toxic that he just wants to be like the
best guitar player he could be and the
best vocalist he could be and like
honestly like I feel like at points in
time like it has made him annoying yeah
um so it's the fact that it's something
he like actively knows that he does and
like works on like actually really like
is relatable like yeah and I respect
that I respect that I understand how an
incident like this could make him be
even more annoying about it and like
striving to be perfect yeah and just
really devastate him yeah well I'm quite
literally running home to go watch his
performance I'm so curious and it is
funny that's also I just think like a
relatable thing in life like there are
things in your life that you feel like
were such big deals like that really
like shaped who you are and quite
literally nobody cares like I don't like
I'm a huge country music fan I have
quite literally no idea what he's
talking about no I know but I'm sure at
the time like it was really big but it
also feels really big when you're in the
center of it it and like still the worst
thing that's ever happened to you just
because it's not as bad as the worst
thing that happened to someone else like
it's still hard for you to go through
yeah no of course but in in that moment
you think it's the biggest thing going
on in the world yeah and then in
retrospecting those things take time you
realize like nobody cared yeah well also
they landed him in therapy which is
always a good thing yeah but then it
made him more of a perfectionist like so
the therapist should be fired right
right I thought he was working on his
perfectionism yeah like
he didn't heal well from this incident
right up until today well he's talking
about it which is a good sign I mean
it's
eight years later wow I cannot wait to
go watch yeah same just to like kind of
see the look on his face like that's
what's most interesting when like live
TV goes wrong how people like hold their
composure I find to be the most
interesting part of it but I also fully
understand how this could happen like to
have a brain fart like sometimes it's
like I know my credit card number
backwards and forwards but like if you
were to ask me like sometimes I'm like I
don't I don't know no and then like your
muscle memory just like gives out yeah
and I think no matter how many times you
perform in front of like a lot of people
like it's always a little bit jarring to
be in like an arena full of people and
on a televised program you know even the
most you could like literally just like
black out it's a muscle memory and yeah
just like start to doubt yourself and it
all goes to [__] I think that all the
time about like dancers like the
choreograph choreography like it's like
you know minutes long choreography how
on God's green diddly Earth do they
remember that like I'm always singing
that when I'm watching um like era's
tour content it's like a three hour show
like and you don't mess up just like one
dance
true and I know that they're
professionals like that's why I can't
wrap my mind around it your muscles get
used to it but then like sometimes it
could happen where you just like doubt
yourself but at least in that situation
there's other people doing it so you
could pick it back up that's true that's
true
but still look I have mad respect for
like dancers it's because all you have
to be giving it your all yada but
there's also so much brain work in
Remembering like oh kickball change
comes next
yeah like that [__] really like
impresses me I think was like Broadway
people memorizing their life oh my God
that is something I actually am in awe
of like
Broadway specifically because it's not
like you can like cut and get a line but
even in movies like people memorize
especially like long for like Law and
Order like they memorize so many lines
like they do like 25 episodes a season
and yeah they get to cut and stuff but
for the most part you need to have your
lines down I don't know how that works
no way like yeah you could forget for
sure but like you for the bulk you need
to know what's going on in the story
yeah in order to know how to act I guess
it's part of the talent yeah the trade
no but Broadway like theater actors that
is beyond impressive yeah
it's like three hour shows
it's crazy
and I've actually been to a lot of shows
I don't think I've ever seen anybody
[__] up a line
maybe you wouldn't know right because
they like covered they have ways but
it's Perfection like it always is yeah
hmm are you ready for our next story no
okay I'm not okay you want to know why
yes because today's episode
is brought to you by you Cora it has
been a minute since we've spoken about
you Cora actually fun fact was one of
our first sponsors ever and I've still
by the way like six years later I still
use the product when I need to yep so do
you get UTIs well the founder of ukora
Jenna did and one year she got eight
UTIs she was miserable and desperate for
a way to get ahead and that inspired her
to start ucora so if peeing after sex
and or drinking cranberry juice just
isn't cutting it then you need to try
ukora some people just need more support
so if UTIs affect your life check out
ukora they make UTI relief products that
help you manage your symptoms and help
you manage your symptoms until you can
see a doctor and they make effective
urinary tract supplements so you can
finally get proactive about your urinary
health for listeners if you want to text
toast to 64 000 you'll get 30 off your
first order so yukora was founded by
chronic UTI sufferer and her husband who
were frustrated with the lack of options
available they have built-in
collaborations with Physicians and
scientists yukora takes an Innovative
scientific approach to ukora's health so
if you feel like you know you're
affected by UTIs maybe more than the
average or you're just like really kind
of getting tired of it you can get
proactive about your urinary tract
health and start actively doing things
before a UTI shows up you can get your
life back today with you Cora get an
additional 30 off your order when you
text toast to 64 000 that's toast to 64
000 to get 30 off your order
message and data rates may apply not all
carriers covered see terms and details
on these statements have not been
evaluated by the Food and Drug
Administration these products are not
intended to diagnose treat cure and
prevent any disease so again text toast
to 64 000 to get 30 off today's episode
is also brought to you by Lululemon the
shorts from Lululemon specifically were
made to stretch flex and support the
infinite ways of working out giving you
the courage to LEAP into something
totally new and unexpected save a bunch
of new shorts at Lululemon that we're
really excited about like the hottie hot
short that give you a comfortable range
of motion and a flattering fit the
hottie hot shorts allow you to Max your
strides you can freely move with
confidence they're lightweight Swift
fabric lets in airflow so you can move
without baggage and they're designed to
Wick away any sweat before you even
notice that it's there they also have
the Wonder train short the shore with
supportive stretch that keeps you dry
powered by the everlux fabric the Wonder
train collection manages heat and sweat
so you stay comfortable and focused the
sweat wicking and quick drying material
of everlex fabric absorbs moisture and
Wick sweat during the most even intense
training or just the most intense hot
summer day like when when you're running
to the grocery store one until cute in
your shorts but like you're getting you
know swamp ass and crotch sweat
all the shorts from Lululemon like are
taking care of your girlies on on even
the most dire of situations whether
you're running a marathon or run into
the grocery store
um get into the Lululemon shorts at
lululemon.com I feel like everything
from Lululemon is really high quality
it's a brand that you can trust they
last for many many seasons if you work
out you run you go to the gym obviously
Lululemon is a brand that comes to mind
but even if you don't you're just like
you know running around town a lot
getting hot in the summer months you
want like a moisture wicking you want a
brand that you can trust that's like
making actual good products for summer
you know to take care of the
undercarriage so again Lululemon shorts
are available what the under I know
under pair just like a funny word kind
of gorgeous much better than what you
said which was swamp ass and crotch
sweat so Lululemon shorts are available
at
lululemon.comlemon.com undercarriage
that's not a real joke that's not real
that's not real but it should
so who knows what happens yeah
okay our next Story the divorce between
Kim and Corey is getting even Messier
last week we reported that she accused
him of being addicted to drugs to drugs
and now Croy is saying that Kim's
gambling problem financially devastated
the family
um you know what there is like a a
record of that so Kim Croy claims that
Kim's gambling has financially
devastated their family the former NFL
players requesting a new court documents
obtained by Page Six that the former
Real Housewives of Atlanta Star undergo
psychological evaluation because of the
compulsions she's presented Kim has
allegedly been quote spending
substantial time in material marital
funds on gambling and other games of
chance he claims in the documents and
this compulsion has financially
devastated the parties he further
alleged that Kim's time is so consumed
with online gambling that she cannot
probably take care of their four minor
children so this is you know a
shit-slinging competition about who and
why they can't take care of their kids
although I do want to say they want her
tested for mental health issues such as
depression narcissistic personality
disorder bipolar disorder and more okay
that obviously like to me feels like a
stretch however like in terms of the
[__] being slung like
if you watch the show she like loves to
gamble and it's definitely like fun but
you know that is a slippery slope like I
feel like there's more proof like more
of a record that she's a gambler than
him being like addicted to drugs you
know what I mean yeah agreed I also feel
like he would have thrown in alcoholism
because there's a long record of her
drinking all the time on the show like
not in a way that was ever concerning to
viewers but like you could make the case
because I feel like they're just at this
point trying to make a case for why the
other shouldn't have right today and
this is like the type of situation where
like actually having spent years on a
reality show really doesn't work in your
favor because like there's tons of
footage and maybe they just went you
know to have content but her at the
casino you know yeah now that's just
like in people's minds and there's a
record of it so it kind of works against
you in a situation like that but like
that was a huge storyline like she you
know when they took that RV she was only
down because like they were going to a
casino yeah so oof yeah right this is
where it like comes back to bite you in
the ass even though I don't know if it's
necessarily even admissible in court
because it's
art it's art right exactly it can it's
you know it can be said it was scripted
because the law is reason free from
Passion exactly and art is a passion
exactly it is reason free from law and
do you know who said those Immortal
words Fat Bastard exactly
so back to my point which is
I don't think it's admissible but it
like for the public like there's two
things going on now like we're now all
you know eating this up and taking aside
and thinking what's real and then
there's also of course like the actual
legal part of it yeah this is just
extremely messy about as messy as it
gets in a divorce yeah just like trying
to think of the worst possible thing you
could take into partner trying to take
away custody of kids yeah it's bad and
it's bad for those of us who like want
shipped in and we're hoping for like you
know we grew apart I know and like we'll
co-parent
and they both like love their kid those
kids so much because they're each
fighting for like sole custody right
which is kind of crazy
you think they both deserve custody like
if if you know if both parents are good
like
what's wrong with joint Quest today yeah
I don't know
I don't know we'll just have to like
this is just very sad they have so many
kids they were such a happy family like
I'm just I'm really still like I'm in
shock from this I'm still in the face of
like denial yeah it doesn't feel real to
me I know but it's realer than real it's
not even like no it's like and it's
getting bad it's getting bad yeah so
that's the latest update no I really am
upset about this like still doesn't
explain why they got divorced though
yeah though they obviously [__] hate
each other right so maybe that's what
happened because in order to like get to
this point where like you're saying
really disparaging things about the
parent of your child in a legal sense
like where it actually has like
consequences you have to really [__]
hate your ex-husband and like calling
for psychological evaluations drug tests
right like it's dirty it's it's low yeah
we've gotten to a bad point so something
must have happened to initially break up
the marriage to the point where it was
irreparable
yeah
yeah very sad and their kids are just so
cute I just like I really love them I
know and it was really like a fairy tale
if you were there from the beginning you
know like how this was a fairy tale for
Kim
like Not only was he so good looking and
so cute he loved her so much and he
loved her girl so much and they had this
like beautiful family where they
couldn't stop having kids and they just
the more you talk about the fairy tale
nature of their relationships the sadder
this update is no I know that's what I'm
saying like that's why I'm still very
much in the denial phase because if you
if you've been there from the beginning
like you know how like Croy turned Kim's
life around you know they only really
got their own show because he was like
this famous NFL player and then they had
this crazy life together and they had
all these kids and she was just like in
and out of Housewives but then she
became like kind of a new tier of
housewife because she got her own show
he
they were really great for each other
and honestly it makes me really sad and
like they dealt with so much
um with their families like respective
families like his family really did not
like her and he stood by her
and he chose her and their family and
Kim's family was crazy like selling
stories to the Press like I think the
public only ever found out that Ariana
and Brianna that said their names Ariana
Brielle had different fathers because
their Grandma Kim's mom sold a story to
People magazine like it was so terrible
I remember when that was on TV it's like
their families were just like kind of
terrible to them and they were just this
this unit and like the story like
actually makes me so sad I'm gonna let
you have time to process and to grieve
and take your time with coming to terms
with it thank you I've been there I know
are you ready for our fifth and final
story a little irrelevant business news
and like the way they like still loved
each other and were so attracted to each
other like all these years later after
all these kids like it really was
inspirational
love isn't real like for real I'm so
upset
that's why you need to know what
happened so that you can process process
and begin to accept yeah because you
can't just go from like the last season
we saw Don't Be Tardy to this [__]
slinging yeah no you're right okay I'm
sorry I'm done no it's as I said take
your time thanks
fifth final story yeah yeah shall we do
you want to sing a song to lead us in
the final story
[Music]
I'll ship you to the very end
just as for cash in KJ
I went like a more somber like ballad
route this time no it was nice is we
needed that sort of a moose boost to
commemorate to take us into the next
story which is that giphy the app that
has all the gifts has been sold and was
I guess owned by meta they were owned by
men they were owned by meta and they
were sold to Shutterstock for 53 million
dollars which is actually a loss because
meta had paid 400 million dollars for it
well I could I could see a time in which
it was worth 400 million dollars where
like gifts were like oh yeah gifts like
and we were putting them everywhere and
everyone was like making their own and
now they're [__] irrelevant and but I
do like meta made them irrelevant like I
can't tell you how many times I've
downloaded the giphy app on my phone so
that I could have it in my text messages
yeah because I love to send a gif in a
text but you don't need the app to do
that do you do because if you don't it
doesn't come up and and literally give
you out by the way you don't have the
giphy app but you have giphy in your
text messages yes how when you like open
up your text message my application the
little micro the uh with a no no you
press the red microscope thing excuse me
images hashtag image and then you just
search in gifs you don't need the Jiffy
app
the thing about Jiffy and I think part
of the reason why it um look at me I'm
gonna be sending gyps all day now I
always would download the Jiffy app then
it goes save a gif and then no no it
goes then it becomes part of your
applications that are available here
just the red microscope but then like
you know what's that thing called
search no not a microscope not a
stethoscope what is that little that's a
microscope no it's not it's a uh what um
when you hold a microscope a microscope
is like a stationary thing you put your
eye in this is like the Glass circle
with the handle that you put up against
your eye it's called a stethoscope no
it's called um
seeing thing like hold on the Looking
Glass what is it magnifying glass yes
thank you so much I was about to write
seeing magnifier but it's magnifying
glass thank you
um
and I think that's just further proof
why like nothing about giphy Slash Jiffy
whatever you want to call it was
proprietary it was just a database of
GIFs that they didn't own or make it was
just like
curated from the internet so Apple was
able to do it on their own you know you
could say the same thing about YouTube
I could say the same thing about YouTube
yeah I could but nobody ever came and
did YouTube just as good Vimeo tried
tries right and they weren't as good but
like nothing about Gibby is ubiquitous
you know like YouTube is ubiquitous
everyone you need to see a video you're
going to YouTube for a while like when
you would search videos for on Google
they would give you a Google video but
like even they gave up yeah they
actually just bought YouTube yeah
which was pretty smart
um but like meta meta's power is no
longer what it was like when they
released reels there was a time when
they released video they shut down the
world's biggest video app Vine when they
released reels I don't really feel like
they made a huge
impact on Tick Tock what I don't know
real people are real people no I know
but I don't think businesses are just
like waiting for tick tock to be banned
and then I also read a report on Twitter
last week that they're coming out with a
Twitter competitor
and I don't think it's like you know
there was a day and time when they would
have done that it would have shut
Twitter down their power is not what it
what it was like if I had a company now
and meta wanted to buy it like of course
I would sell it to them but like I don't
know if it would be like become the
biggest best company ever you know yeah
and it used to be that way no not
everything they do is successful right
now they're
I don't know what's the future I guess
they think the meta versus the future
you know I personally will not be
engaging in the metaverse or any verses
I like I like this for real life the
universe I just don't understand
I don't understand the metaverse like
why people would want to live there
I literally don't understand it no and I
like saw this like girl complaining that
she got like robbed in the metaverse and
people are getting raped in the
metaverse you're kidding me yeah
I don't know what the laws are there but
can't you just take the glasses off no
like for real like isn't it no I don't
no no no I don't know like the metaverse
like let's just the metaverse is not
real right so somebody steals money from
my wallet in the metaverse like
I still have my wallet in the real world
like you know what I mean yes but no in
the metaverse like you do have like a a
digital wallet so if they take your
money
so the metaverse is like lawlessness
no that's why I'm not getting involved
like yeah I feel like this is one of
those things like everybody was like you
know gangbusters for AI and now it's
like it's literally ruining civilization
and we're all trying to like backtrack
Ai and now we're all like gangbusters
from metaverse and then in a few years
we're gonna be like we wish we never did
that and so I'm not participating in the
charade no and I'm not getting Busters
for my diverse taking me out of that
equation but I just want to say like AI
can do wreak havoc on anything that it
wants but it will never take down the
toes no it won't but like there's no
reason anybody should have like created
that and I think the guy who created it
is like damn sorry y'all like I [__]
up yeah
and I feel like the metaverse is going
to be one of those things
like also whatever happened to nfts you
know it's the same thing like is nft is
over no because like the whole thing
crashed right with FTS like no no
um
like crypto like crashed right crypto
like goes up and down
it went down and I feel like it was
never the same and then FTX also was
really bad for the crypto world yeah and
I just feel like there was a time when
like everyone was talking about nfts and
I feel like we're not talking about it
anymore like I feel like I think it's
like the trend like it's over yeah
like what about all those people that
quit their jobs to work in nfts yeah I
don't know what about like all that nft
art that they bought to hang in there
metaverse house
oh my God the fact that people were out
here using fake money to buy fake art no
using real money to buy fake art to hang
in their fake houses in their fake
Universe like this is like literally not
the real world no could never be made
like I am just like so firmly planted in
the real world and I'm just not one of
these people who could be like taken
away in the metaverse like I'm just I'm
not
good to know and like where do you even
access the metaverse like okay I want to
go to the metaverse so should I put on
goggles like is it a r or we are
no let's seriously say I'd like to join
the metaverse please okay where do you
join let's find out like I'm sure we can
find out for a matter is it like a
website you go to join the metaverse
do you put on goggles join us in the
metaverse building trust okay that's an
ad
what is the metaverse and how to get
into it that's us yeah
big read aloud
he all does the next generation of the
internet big text acolytes have high
hopes for the metaverse but though this
new virtual space may change our lives
it's still largely misunderstood so
ain't that the truth learn what the
metaverse is how to access it and where
it may be heading in the future then
keep yourself safe wherever you go
online with powerful online security and
privacy software like Avast one
so for they want us to download Avast
one okay and so then then what no I need
like how to access the metabolism and
that's an application on your computer
until you open it up like you would like
photos or Safari here's what you need
equipment to enter the metaverse a
computer check gaming console it's not
necessary to access the metaverse but
they are beneficial if you would like to
connect other equipment such as a
microphone and a VR headset okay I have
a PS5 at home but Ben does if you're
interested in socializing in real time
with additional equipment a gaming
console can provide an immersive
experience okay I definitely want to be
immersive VR headset to enter the VR
okay so when people say they're in the
metaverse they're actually like their
eyes are in the metaverse yeah
and the hand operated controllers right
right so you're like really
and AR glasses yeah
look I'm all good you know
I'm set
I'm set even though I will say I went to
um like an arcade like a year ago maybe
less and there was like a game that you
sit in and you put the headset on and
like it's like a roller coaster kind of
and really and it was super fun I don't
know if that's the metaverse but I had a
great time Six Flags in the matter first
no like it was it wasn't even Six Flags
it was like this kind of it kind of
looks like Care Bears it was like this
beautiful like it didn't make you feel
like you want to move there it was just
like a beautiful like rain forest almost
but it was all in pastel colors and like
I was like swirling down this Creek and
I was in this boat and then I was like
it was fun
could you sleep in the metaverse I guess
just like not take your glasses off and
fall asleep just like close your eyes
but then you don't see anything but you
don't see anything when you're sleeping
anyway but then you get to wake up there
oh God that sounds like you don't have
to go back to your life
I don't honestly I don't really believe
in like creating new universes if you
don't like the one that you're in like
you know we all have the hard things in
life like we just got to power through
yeah the metaverse Is Not Gonna Save you
no especially when you're saying it's
running rampant with crime
I go to the metaverse because I'm
unhappy I'm unhappy because I go to
members I think that's a perfect place
down the show like really full circle
that was actually poetic the way we just
kind of started the show and and there's
nothing that needs to be said I go to
the metaverse because I'm unhappy and
I'm unhappy because I go to the
metaverse
that's actually like very poignant I
think that's what's going on I do too
with a lot of people like there's no
reason you should be putting on glasses
and escaping and it's like an episode of
Black Mirror the one with Landry yes no
and there's another one where he like
plays in a video game with his friend
they're like long distance friends and
um they're both men who are straightened
in relationships but when they play in
the video game as their avatars like
once a girl I don't know what their
genders are in the game but they [__]
when they play in the game oh my God and
then they like have to see each other
but they like have this affair going on
in the video game
interesting that sounds like a good
episode the one that I'm referring to is
Landry from Friday Night Lights whose
name I can literally never remember but
he's married to Kirsten Dunst you guys
know him
um he plays his video game at work after
work and when he's at work
he like snatches people from the
workplace and makes her DNA and then
copies them into his video game and they
like live this like eternal life trapped
in the video game but they find a way to
kill him I don't know that's basically
what the metaphor says and he was a
freak and I'm sorry if you're like if
you're not experiencing like you're not
going out and like meeting people and
connecting with other humans and like
traveling and experiencing things you're
just putting on glasses every day to
live in a fake ass world like seriously
that's not okay there's something wrong
with you I'm sorry there is like we all
need to bloom where we're planted and
we've been planted in the universe not
the metaverse no I totally agree so
that's kind of the lesson for today
thank you there's no toast in the
metaverse no because we're like we're
real
we're real people you say what you want
about us we're real
and only real people exist in the
universe it's not the metaverse I'm so
gonna be you're right that did start the
tangent thank you guys so much for
listening to the Dozen Lenny Morning
Show where we deliver the past five
stories you need to know everybody
through Friday on YouTube so you're
watching this on YouTube please don't
forget to subscribe give this video a
thumbs up we're also available
downstairs videos
hope you guys have an amazing day we'll
see you tomorrow for hump day where we
will be doing deer toasters we're back
on schedule we will be I don't see every
reason why we wouldn't be me neither
unless someone comes up unless there's a
jackhammer and right but hopefully we're
good love ya bye